olivier h associés l'isr petit rêve
qu'il a vu annoncer un prix imbattable
rendu à la maison tout heureux il va y
effectuer les branchements nécessaires
il allume et c'est la déception
il n'y a pas d'image le téléviseur ma
fiche que des lignes de toutes les
couleurs ils essayent tous les réglages
rien à faire aucune image ne s'affichent
sur les cas olivier téléphone au magasin
le commerçant lui dit que le problème du
fabricant le deuxième téléphone chez le
fabricant non monsieur lydie ton
problème regarde le commerce ans et de
téléphones en téléphone olivier son
problème devienne la balle de ping pong
on se renvoie le fabricant il
commerçants qui est responsable alors
les deux au québec
la garantie légale est clair un bien que
vous achetez doit fonctionner les
commerçants et les fabricants sont tenus
de respecter cette garantie légale et si
olivier le lui demande
oui le commerçant avec lequel il a le
contrat doit prendre en charge son
téléviseur d'effectuer le bon mot de
l'histoire
sun son lit les commerçants et les
fabricants qui ont le dernier mot sur la
garantie d'un bien que vous avez acheté
c'est la loi